[Applause]
he already said everything but I let me
have a quick introduction of what I am
doing in my life right now I'm the
maintainer of the tool reveals two web
framework which is one of the top 10 web
frameworks in Python country and
maintain of the bigger project for
caching and session which is widely used
by many web frameworks contributed to me
Tosca widgets were Bobcat yogi as you
can see all web related projects so most
of my time is spent in the web world
with Python and from the work point of
view I'm one of the founders of a
company in Italy technical PI's over
three startups in Italy and one of the
engineers behind the crunch dollar your
project which is great projects to don't
know it have a look and reason why I
decided to speak about this topic is
because I recently published the book
which is named modern I don't start the
library cookbook as as you can guess it
talks about the Python standard library
why I decided to write such a book when
item is full of great documentation
great books and things like that the
reason is that most of the cookbooks
that are available for Python are
actually about the language the core
feature of the language some of them
showcase some features that are
available to the standard library but
most of the focus is about the language
itself and we have some great sources
for documentation about the standard
library like the documentation itself
the Python module of the week project
and things like that but they try to
focus on how you can use those models
how they work like they act more like a
reference when you already know that
they exist they are not a very
convenient way to discover new models or
corner cases or ways you can use those
models and the Python standard library
it's really huge
I still discover new features and models
and functions every day and I've been
using it for like 15 years or something
like that and this is actually a very
interesting topic because
there was a proposal to reduce the
amount of modules included in Astana
library because they so big that the
burden over the maintainer is not
manageable anymore
some models are maintained for years
because no one has knowledge about them
there are not enough people willing to
maintain the standard library to
maintain it at its current site so sadly
in the next years it's going to shrink
but still it has some very cool Eden
gems that I want to share with you the
first one that I want to show review is
how to report crashes from your
production applications or like any kind
of application actually this is
something that I consider very important
for any kind of application want to know
that there is an issue because you get
notified by your monitoring system not
because you usually come and complain to
you so you want to be aware of any kind
of issue before it can impact an user or
before it impacts them enough that they
start complaining and being reported of
crashes is one of the best way that you
can not erase a bug in your code because
as much as you can test your application
as much you could have a quality
assurance process the users will always
discover bugs because the complexity of
the world out there is much bigger than
anything we can replicate in a
constrained environment like our testing
systems and things like that so this is
an example of what I want to achieve
which is every time the application
crashes it sends me an email with the
trash trace back and the error and this
can be achieved actually in a very
simple manner to the logging model in
Python
I guess that most of you who have used
the logging module at least once in your
life but I think that not many people
know that the loading model is actually
very flexible it can be configured in
many ways the logging model structure in
a way that you have what's called
Engler's which are in charge of doing
something
you'll submit a message to the logging
system and one of the things that they
can do is actually send forward that
message to you through an SMTP server so
you can get your log by email whenever
the login system outputs a new log entry
that's of course not very convenient for
logging yourself you don't want to reach
thousands of email every time you
provide something under logging but if
used properly it can be a very good way
to provide ins about some specific
messages and in this case what I'm going
to do is decorate a function usually the
main of your software or the main of
your whiskey application in case of web
applications we have a decorator that
every time there is an exceptions it
calls the exception logging out there on
the logger that we just configure if you
notice in the video space the crash
trash logger is configured to send every
entry by email and here we tell the
logger to record the new exception the
the conveniences that the exception
helper actually does not only record the
message which is going to be used as the
subject of the email but it also records
the trace back and line where we crashed
and things like that so if this is used
properly you are going to receive my
mail every single hour that your
application faces so that you know
before your users start to complain and
this requires like two lines of code you
just decorate the entry point of your
application or the most important
functions and you get notified it works
especially well in the context of web
development because you have a single
entry point in the wall application that
it's called by the whiskey server every
time it has two server requests so every
time the request crashes you get
notified for that specific request
another cool feature that's available in
the Python standard library very few
people know about is that you have a way
to
and literal objects if you have a word
with other dynamic languages like
probably JavaScript because it's the
most widespread one you probably got
used to having literal objects and be
able to just go around objects are
located at any point in your code with
any kind of properties and not having to
declare classes or proper structures and
things like that
that's not the way best way to organize
your code but it can be very convenient
when experimenting or when writing tests
that have to simulate the behavior of
other objects and you don't want to end
up using real mocks or things like that
whenever acting around in general it can
be convenient to be able to declare
objects that don't require a proper
class hierarchy to be created and
usually in Python you frequently end up
using dictionaries for this purpose
because you can put anything you want in
the dictionary but if you have two code
called third parties code it's going
probably to accept some kind of
dictionary or some kind of object and
not playing each other as the argument
so the problem with dictionaries is that
they do not support the dot notation for
the assess to their content and that's
the reason why in this and the library
we have something like the namespaces
where you can actually set any property
you like they act like additionally
nothing different but the measure
different from this analysis that you
can assess all the properties that are
inside an in-space with the dotted
notation so in practice you can create a
namespace everywhere and pass them
around and as we are talking about a
fully dynamic language there will be
accepted by all the function that you
need to call as far as they have the
properties that they expect so you reach
nearly the same level of little objects
that you can achieve in other languages
like JavaScript and so on and another
very cool feature I want to talk you
about is that the fact that Python
provide
the spoof temporary files this is a kind
of temporary file that not frequent he
is he used in code but it can be very
convenient for some reasons I think that
all of you had the least once in their
life they need to store some data in
memory in the form of a file or read it
or something like that and frequently we
end up using the bytes on your as the
way to store this data to keep this data
round the problem with bytes a yo is
that it rolls as far as your memory
allows it so in canson context where you
have constrained resources or where we
have multiple processes running for the
same resources this can be a problem
because like let's say that you are
storing in a byte say or a file that was
applauded by a user to your web
application if the users applauds at 20
gigabytes file and it's able to actually
send it to you you are going to consume
20 gigabytes of memory and that's going
to be a problem if your system doesn't
have 20 gigabytes of memory or if you
system as other processes that compete
for the same memory and the solution to
this problem is usually to ally on on
disk file like temporary files most web
frameworks end up storing when you
submit a file they actually store it as
a temporary file on disk somewhere and
they return you an ASUS to death
temporary file and this is cool because
it solves the memory consumption problem
the disk is really far bigger than the
memory you have available so it
shouldn't be a major problem but has the
problem that it has a major performance
impact the disk is far slower than your
memory and in some cases you can be also
trottle by the maximum number of you
operation every second you can do and
things like that like especially if you
are on a shell file system like elastic
file system or things like that there
you have a maximum number of i/o
operations that you can do across the
world cluster so if you have man
nerds that are writing a reading on the
same file system you're probably going
to eat there are your limit before you
eat the bandwidth limit the solution to
this problem is actually available in
the Sun library and prevents you from
facing these kind of problems that this
is actually real logs from application
that has been continuously key on a web
application you see Apache is usually
the process the clock picked by the moon
Kela just because the user was
applauding very big files in the intent
to bring down the system on purpose and
it was such a seeming at doing that but
if you use the spool time for a file you
are going to get the best of the both
words what's going to happen is that as
far as the file is smaller than the
specified mark side python is going to
work on it in memory so it's going
practice to use something like bytes are
you everything happened since memory is
very fast you can work it on nearly
real-time and things like that
but if your files grows further myself
inside it gets swapped please so you
don't have to care about your users
exhausting or your memory or things like
that and this is probably the best
solution to that kind of problem because
for realistic sizes for those that will
be 90% of your requests you are going to
process them quickly memory and for big
requests that might be malicious or
might be an exception you are going just
be a bit slower because you are flawed
them to the DS but you're not going to
crash any more
another interesting problem that it's
frequently it in some kind of
application is proper output alignment
and display if you ever brought the
terminal application you probably faced
the case where it takes you a few hours
to provide the output you you want to
provide a proof of concept of your web
creation and you spend the rest of the
day is trying to format it in a way that
works in a reasonable way
on all sides and kinds of terminals
however you users might have decided to
recite their window and things like that
that's a very hard problem that not
frequently many software out there that
has been around for years are not very
good at solving and for to show you this
case I picked a very common example
which is a progress bar progress bar
very widespread they are very recognized
and known way to show to you users the
progress of some kind of operation but
they are also very good example for this
case because if you don't format
properly a progress bar your user is not
going to understand anything it would be
just a huge mess of things on each
screen and will lose any ability to
provide the information that you want
for example this is the progress bar
from real software
existing out there and you can see that
at a certain point it just gets a huge
mess of truncated data and one point it
goes on a new line it's really hard to
understand what what's going on is it
progressing at all
at which point my right now and things
like that
so this is why you want to make sure
that your software is properly able to
adapt to the screen size of your users
and the standard library actually has a
way to do that and I use that utility to
implement a progress but that adapts
properly to the sides of the screen and
here you can see the example it's very
simple to use you just decorate the
function that has to report the progress
and yield any progress advancement from
that function so the function can
compute whatever it has to compute write
the result whenever it has to write it
and meanwhile it can report progress by
yielding values back to the decorator
and the output the result is as you can
see they're nicely formatted progress
part in the implementation is pretty
straightforward it's just a function
that loops and continuously consumes
data from you were decorated function
your decorated function there is the
it's called to retrieve the generator
you see jan equal func and then it just
goes on calling forever next over your
generator so the implementation is not
the interesting part here the
interesting part here is that in the Shu
TL method and su Shi module sorry you
have a way to grab the where is it I
can't find it anymore here sorry at the
top you have a way to grab the current
terminal side so you are able to adapt
the output of your function to the
current sides of the terminal window and
this will take care for view of most of
the complexity because it's not
something very simple it depends on the
terminal configuration kind of system
you are on on Windows it's different
than on UNIX systems and things like
that so it's not a very straightforward
information to achieve but the standard
library takes care of making sure you
get back something meaningful for you
and even better if I move these
information within the while loop it
will also adapt if the user resizes on
real time the windows so I don't have to
care about it let's see the next feature
available in the standard library how to
survive an atomic sellout
not really actually it's how to survive
atomic right so in many web applications
there is a need to replace the content
of say file of some data that you are
storing on disk suppose like an upload
an image or something like that only if
you successfully brought it for real if
you completed writing if your process
gets
killed in the middle of the riot if you
process crashes in the middle of the
right of things like that
we shouldn't I have not corrupted the
file we were replacing this is actually
a very common problem for nearly all
applications that have to store data
like think of your database system would
you be happy if you were inserting data
and if it crashes in the middle of
insertion you corrupted the whole
content of the database that's probably
not something that's going to make you
very happy but most of the application
also arounds after from ease bug from
this issue the if you interrupt a bride
that will have corrupted the data
because the way their system frights the
data is by writing in chunks of bytes so
if interrupts in the middle of two
chunks you only brought the first part
of the data and probably you end up with
a file that has half of the previous
content at alpha of the new content that
makes no sense at all or it might have
only Alf of the new content so it's
still truncated invalid data and we can
implement using the standard library a
utility that makes you safe from this
kind of issue and it will also allow us
to retain the same exact behavior who
are you we are used to when working with
the plain open function we are just
going to use safe open instead of open
and then we can write a read from that
file without caring about the fact that
it will guarantee for us the atomic
price to the file so if we use the safe
open in case our codes crash in the
middle of writing it will all work back
to the previous state of the file and
implementation is very straight forward
we are going again to rely on a very
convenient model of the Pancoast on a
library which is the temporary file
module the temporary file module is a
kind of temporal file which is the name
the temporary file it means that you
don't only get back handle that gives
you access to that temporary file but
give us back actual file name on these
so something on which we can call more
functions based on the filename itself
and why is that important because by
virtue of the fact that we are within
the context manager when you open a file
we actually don't open this file but we
open a temporary file so we are going to
write to a new file and not to the one
you were targeting to so in this example
you see that I opened TMP my file and
what I'm going to do is that instead of
opening TMP my file I'm actually going
to open a temporary file somewhere on
the disk then my code works on that
temporary file and only if it succeeds
all if it succeeds the temporary file is
closed and then the file is renamed so
it's moved to the place that was
previously used by the file we wanted to
open and this works because as far as
you are on the same file system so you
are not moving across two different
beasts or a remote filesystem things
like that those fabulous you are on the
same file system the rename operation
will be atomic there is no way to
interrupt alph way every name it's
already named it or not so at the end I
brought the wall content on my file or
not because I was able to up and and the
wall functional rename my temporary file
to the target file and and so I replaced
the target file with the data that I
brought on the temporary file or I
failed doing that and so I didn't really
think my temporary file is left there
and my my target file is still there as
it was before doesn't even know that
something was written somewhere instead
if I get an exception I just throw away
that I'm horrified and nothing was ever
written my target file is still in the
same exhaust rate it was before and we
can see all these words
with this simple example you say that in
the first case I obviously just open the
file and write the content and if I read
it back and we see hello world because I
wrote everything and closed my context
manager while in the second example I
opened my file I write some content and
I throw an exception which will cause my
code to exit from the context manager
now if I point back the content of my
file what do you expect to see
it's important to notice that in this
example I use the standard open so I
didn't use my safe open and for these
fees on what I'm going to see is only
the first line of their content my
previously written el award is thrown
away in the Catherine place we might
replace the yellow world but I never add
the second part of the text written on
disk which is what you expect it's very
straightforward to understand its
content the problem is that i thrown
away the previous content of the file
it's lost forever but i didn't finish
writing the new content that i wanted to
drive while instead if we use the safe
open for the same exact example if i
read back the content of the file after
the crash of my codebase i won't read
replace the award but i will actually
read l word nothing was ever written to
my file by virtue of out there safe open
context manager works so I didn't
corrupt my previous data in any way I
didn't write anything and everything is
as it was before it's like having the
transaction system for files if you fail
you can roll back the content of the
file to the previous state and be happy
one more feature that's available in
astana library and very few people know
about is the multi processing manager
some people probably used it in the past
too and ended up relying on it to share
data across multiple processes
it's very common it's the reason why it
was born it's a it's a way to share data
across processes you can store any value
inside the manager and that value will
be available to all the processors the
chef the same manager so you can write
multi processing software without having
to manually share the data across the
processes any data that you store in the
manager will be available readable from
all the processes that are children of
the process that for the manager and
they can replace the daytime things like
that it's like having a database where
you can store the data you want to share
across all your system by the
interesting feature is that very few
people know how the manager actually
works in the way it works is that it
actually forms a sub process of your
process and the sub process is a fully
functional in memory database system the
listings for requests through TCP so the
point is that from any process on any
machine you would be able to connect
that process to the manager and store
data there you don't even need to be a
child of the process that for the
manager as far as you know which port
and address is listening you can write a
read data to that manager so what we
actually have is a fully functional
database system without having to start
or manage any database system for a very
simple project this can become a
convenient way to store the data and
permit assets across different
processors from different machines and
it's easy to see that if you pair the
manager with the Shelf module you
actually implemented a fun differential
a database system because
shelve on disk or the data that it's in
the manager and you can restore it from
disk the next time the manager start so
let's see how it works in this case I'm
going for convenience to just rely on
the fact that I formed the manager so
that I don't have to show you what the
machinery involved in to connecting to a
remote manager because the example is
already pretty long like this and didn't
fit in a single slide so let's suppose
we have a first process that right
that's at 42 as a value in the manager
and the second process that set a deep
as the second body in the manager and
the last process the set day type as the
value in the manager those three
variables first second and last will be
available to a fourth process that is
able to read their content and print
them as far as that process knows about
the manager so as far as they were
forked all from the same parent they can
read and write to the same manager and
that is available to all the processes
that are sharing that same manager the
only thing you need to make sure is that
you don't fork the manager in the middle
of your code because the way it was told
you makes a fork of your project so you
don't want your code dynamically forking
processes copying the world memory of
your process including there all the
data that you did store in that process
because you probably know that forking
relies on the copy-on-write poverty but
you probably don't remember that Python
has built in a reference counting so
anytime you assess an object you are
actually going to break the copy of
write because you have to increment the
reference counting in the object so for
king and copyright in python they're not
very efficient as you would expect and
here there is the example that I told
you where you can actually assess the
namespace from any machine on
system as far as they are connected to a
network and you can see that I can
create a manager and tell the manager
that it's going to listen to the part
50,000 I'm specified just because that
way I know which part is listening to
otherwise it's something dynamic that I
will never know and then I tell to the
manager to self connections forever so I
just start a process that stays there
blocked and listen for requests and goes
on and on serving any requests that he
receives and from a second process I
make a another manager that instead of
listening for requests connect to the
other manager so I can talk to the
second manager to connect to the other
manager and interesting part is that if
I set a value in the first manager like
in this case I set five in value the
other process it's perfectly able to
tween that value even do that value was
totally different machine doesn't even
have to be on the same machine because
we are relying on the network
connections you just need to pay
attention to the fact that the models if
you start complex objects like classes
or things like that those modules need
to be available on both systems because
otherwise we will face peeking issues of
course but that's the only real real
thing you need to care about as far as
you have the same environment and both
machines you are able to send values
back and forth across the one network
without having to care too much one more
really convenient feature that I found
think that many of you had faced at
least once in your life is that if you
have to write our HTML output maybe a
web page maybe send an email you know
that you need to escape anything that
you place in that email and that the
user provided to you because otherwise
if the user provided malicious content
like JavaScript or similar you are going
to send to the Browse
of your users that JavaScript Aziz and
it would be executed and it can be a
very powerful factor of attacks this is
still a very common issue in web
applications like 90% of the security
reports that you can find for website
hotel I usually through this vector
which means that this is something we
developers are not very good at handling
and the most common way to end of this
problem is by doing manual escapes on
every single page where you inject a
value in the output and that's not
something that works because it's got
boring and tedious and humans are not
very good at doing boring things they
start to skipping them saying here will
never happen anything and things like
that or they forget and so on so the
best approach to this problem is
actually having escaping by default if
the software escape everything unless
you explicitly don't want to escape it
so you don't have to remember to escape
things and in worst case you wish or
something that is broken to the user but
it's not malicious in any way and the
way we can achieve this is through the
standard library formato
if you know the way you have the format
strings in Python as being based on the
swing formatter a training that we
implemented on top of this thing format
but they provide the same exact feature
but the thing for matter is something
that we can customize so it provides the
string formatting feature to a class
that we can customize in this example I
made an HTML format that allows me to
format HTML and why is that important
because every time I replace a value in
my target string it actually gets
escaped for me so if you see in the
output the strong name was escaped so I
didn't put HTML in the result I properly
escaped that but the title where I
explicitly stated that it's markup so I
want to
markup was not escape was formatted
disease okay
there are very cool eyebrows out there
that take off these the most famous part
I think it's marks up safe from the
flask guys but the it's something that
you can easily achieve without the need
of any external dependency or anywhere
framework at all it's available
understand a library itself just by sub
classing the string formatter and the
way this thing formatter works is that
every time it has to replace a value
every time it has to format a value it's
going to call the get field me Todd it's
going to tell the girls with me today I
need the value of this variable like in
this case we are the name and title so
every time therefore matters to a
resolve name and every term interest
rates off title it's going to call the
field method and what we can do is that
after we actually retrieved that value
from the class from the parent class we
can check if that value is a markup
value and the protocol of which the
markup trust is based is that it has a
underscore underscore HTML method so if
so our class if our value is the mark-up
based class respects the mark-up
protocol we are going to put it as is or
more than Aziz formatted as a HTML so
call the proton while instead if our
value is not markup we are going to
escape it if it's a string let's escape
it that way every time we format a value
it gets escaped automatically and we
don't have to remember to escape it and
here you can see a very simple
implementation of the mark-up portable
it just rely on having a H and under
HTML method the returns disk the HTML
representation of that object which in
case of a string it's testing itself so
it's very simple it just way to tag a
string as something that has two
the format a disease instead of being
escaped so you can see that in five
lines of code you actually end up having
the same Excel feature that you will
lack by installing the external
dependency and it's official that can
save your life in many contexts I think
that most of you already know this comic
stripe but this is very fun one last
thing I want to show you actually two
last things I want to show you but this
is one of my favorite as I told you I'm
involved in web development and I'm
maintaining my framework so it's very
fun for me to talk about how to provide
a web framework and it's something that
we can do in five minutes
through the standard library because if
you look very well into the Sunna
library you will see that you have all
the pieces that you need to write a
fully functional web application that
take care of the most complex part of
handling of web requests for you so this
is the web framework that I brought only
relying on the standard library and it
might look like something that you
already used in your life it's very
similar we just declare a risky
application and then attach all the
function that we want to route that gets
out for us and the routes can be even
complex like having regular special
arguments everything say that so anytime
I assess the route I will see a la ward
anytime assess mink return you click
link try this other link and then it
gets me to an endpoint
except some argument and I can print
back the arguments and things like that
okay so it particular fully functional
web framework for most basic moves and
at the end I just have my web
application so it will list a non HTTP
for me the two root concepts that I use
as a convenience you don't really need
to do that but it can be convenient to
represent the incoming data and the
outgoing data to to response and request
classes that's what you're probably is
doing other work Emmer's and the
response class or needs to take care of
whirring what's the status that you want
to take to send back and what the others
that you want to send back and then
provide the simple metal to send back
that response why the request is going
to keep in memory or the information
that God sent to us by the browser and
allow us to read what was the requested
path what was the request that arguments
and things like that they were frame
were itself it's just these code nothing
more nothing less
so it's very simple the route decorator
which is the one we used here to
register the values and points just
saves the endpoints you wanted to
register into a list of available
endpoints so it keeps some well recorded
that for this URL we want to call this
method nothing else of course as the end
point can be a regular expression we
compiled as very very special the some
method
it's even simpler because you reply
relies on some either it's ready-made in
astana library the Whiskey reference
sample so we create a web server a
whiskey server that we listen on port
8000 and every single request that gets
received on that part is forwarded to
self so to yourself to your web
application and it's forwarded by
calling the provided callable object so
in this case by calling our dunder
committed so every time we receive a
request we get the dunder call method
call and what we do is that we create
the request representation we check if
any of there is a register the route
matches with the request path that we
got and then we call it so we just
called the registry endpoint we get bad
the response that they had provided us
and we send back the response to the
browser that's all so it's very safe
forward look if there is any registered
callback for the end
called a callback get the results on the
callback and send back the result to
their browser that's all you need to
implement a fully functional web
framework ad will say white through that
I lied you will notice the property if
you start doing these in two weeks
you're still writing a web frameworks
and three months it will be two million
lines of code and things like that and
in three years you will be the
maintainer of one more word framework in
Python so don't do that because Django
flask or whatever you want but it can be
convenient if you only want to give you
expose to three endpoints in a web
application that maybe has to run in
constrained environment where you don't
have enough memory space or a properly
functional package manager to install
dependencies or things like that or you
just don't want to bother maintaining
dependencies and things like that five
lines of code and you are apu with your
own web support the last way CP i want
to show you is based on code tracing
this is not something that you are going
to use in your code itself when it's
something that can be convenient to
understand other people code so whenever
you use in your library or whenever you
have to approach a new code base it can
be very hard to understand what's going
on you know nothing about the library of
that code base so it takes time before
you start understanding how it works at
the general level of a visual about
their library works and in my experience
the best way to start understanding
death start having that vision it's by
following what goes on when you run the
library so look at which lines of code
get executed let us look at which
argument gets passed around follow the
execution of the library or of the
application you are trying to understand
the problem is that when you try to do
this with the buggers
they focus on the specific line you are
executing and after a while you lose the
global vision
what's going on after the term dime you
end up deep into their stack of fine
from course you don't even remember
anymore where you came from you you have
all the information you care about about
the single current line of code you have
the context of the code surrounding the
line of code where you are but you
probably forgot where you came from so
it's not very good to have a global
vision of what's going on into the
application as a world and a very good
way to have that global vision is to
rely on tracing of the world code so
this is a very example simple example
that I did and I asked to the tracer to
trace the execution of function and what
function function is a very simple
function and just like does the sum of
two numbers and as you can see I get
back the printed code and I get a little
plus near to all the lines that were
executed so you can see that in this
execution I didn't enter this if and so
I didn't print this this message I just
got a 1b to return a plus B and so I
understood what's going on why didn't
print that message because it never
passed the D if and things like that of
course in this very simple example it's
obvious to understand but it's already a
good way to understand what your code
bed contains and it can surprise you
like this food that contains human flesh
and not sure I'm going to try how is
that all implemented it's based on the
trace model so inside Python itself
inside the cell either itself you have
the trace model which allows you to
trace the execution of code base and
what we do it just every time the tracer
provides us informations we record that
information somewhere and then to the
print trace execution we print the code
base with the information of which lines
got executed so it's very
straightforward to understand you just
record which line where trace and then
print
slides back so you can see all modules
that got executed in which order which
lines were executed and try to
understand which is the full flow of a
function call that you did that was the
last recipe that I wanted to share with
you if you want to see more recipes of
course go read the book and thank you
for your attention
you